Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my Full House of the Dragon Episode 3 video there
were a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
for Game of Thrones so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel I'm doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them careful for spoilers for the episode if
you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shop by
shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments
starting with the beginning of the episode so the
title of the episode is called second of his name
it's a reference to Prince aegon the second he'll
become aegon II if he sits on the Iron Throne
eventually there's a lot of confusion over the way
they use this convention too like for instance Jon
Snow would have been called aegon the sixth if
he'd actually sat on the Iron Throne so right
now where he is on the show he's not considered
the successor even though all the Lords as we
learned during the episode just assume that aegon
will be eventually named the air and take the Iron
Throne when he comes of age so technically right
now aegon isn't called aegon the second he just
called Prince aegon when he takes the iron
tone or if he takes the Iron Throne that's
when he'll officially be called aegon the second
and that's why the title of the episode is sort
of foreshadowing for the future of the story and
the actual Dance of the Dragons this battle over
this succession but as predicted they did add
a little bit of new footage to the actual intro
scene they kind of did the same thing that they
did during the Game of Thrones original series
episodes on the Game of Thrones series because
they were using the map they would just show
the different locations that were featured during
each episode and that's how they would change the
intro but because the house the dragon intro
is like a model of old valyria done as their
family tree like the blood of old Valeria flowing
through all the sigils of the members in the line
of succession the extra thing they added for this
episode was like a little bloodline coming from
alicent because aegon has been born now obviously
she's pregnant with another child I'll mention
that in a second too but because the child hasn't
been born yet they might add another line when
the child is eventually born because the trailer
show us a bunch of footage of the older versions
of characters and there are a bunch more kids will
probably eventually see more lines coming out of
the different sigils the actual opening scene
is down in the stepstone sort of setting up the
whole War of the stepsons itself they explain it's
been a three your time Jump in-house velaryon men
Daemon's men are basically fighting a slow War of
Attrition even though they have their dragons and
that's a huge Advantage they've been fighting
a losing War over the past couple of years and
that's why they keep petitioning the crown for
support they don't do a very good job of showing
you during this episode because it's not like a
massive huge huge battle but the whole idea is
there's a triarchy vastly vastly outnumbered their
forces it was really the dragons that balanced
things out for them love that payoff scene with
Daemon coming in on caraxes and just roasting the
entire field we see kragus drejar feeding one
of their men to the crabs as they kept saying
during previous episodes crying out for the sea
snake and Daemon Targaryen who he said would come
to help him who kind of do but kind of do not at
the same time I think the whole idea what Daemon
crushing him with karaxi's is just an idea that
Daemon is there for himself like the whole idea
is that he's there to attain fortune and Glory the
thing Corliss used to sell him on the idea of the
campaign was seizing glory for himself and so far
because they've been fighting a losing battle he
hasn't found any Glory so it's just another way
to show you that even though Daemon yes wants to
get rid of the triarchy because the triarchy sucks
they're basically choking trade here in this area
Daemon is really here for selfish reasons they do
use this extended scene with cracksis to kind of
show you what it's like with a dragon in battle
it's like a cool Twist on the dragon battles that
makes fun of cragas drahar for being a bastard his
father for being a bastard it does make me wonder
if there was something special going on with
his bloodline like is he part of the Valyrian
bloodline somehow is he distantly related to the
targaryens there's a lot of theories on that but
they kind of go nowhere during the episode I
think the way they just set this up the whole
idea of second Sons is that they wanted to show
you that Daemon was searching for Glory to prove
himself because of the way that he's viewed in the
line of succession by the rest of the realm right
now in cragas drahar is trying to do the same
thing too so that's why crab feeder is leading
this Army trying to seize this area for himself he
does have grayscale and his mask is also a cobbled
together version of the sons of the harpy mask and
for those of you wondering because Daemon hauls
him out people are wondering if you're touching
someone who has grayscale does that mean that
Daemon now has grayscale too is that going to kill
him eventually I think if that had been the case
like if he'd actually contracted grayscale just by
touching him here they would have zoomed in on the
part of his body that was actually touching crab
feeder and I think he would have actually tried
to hide the fact that he was touching crab feeder
and because he didn't do that I think they're just
trying to tell us that no he did not get grayscale
then when we go back to King's Landing we find out
that aegon II is having his second birthday and
that's how much time has gone by like it's a three
year time Jump but that gives you enough time
for alicent and need to get remarried then for
her to have aegon and for him to have his second
birthday the person Otto Hightower is talking to
is his older brother Hobart Hightower the current
Lord Hightower down in Old Town right now and it's
just meant to set up the idea that pretty much
all the Lords of the realm just expect viserys
to eventually name aegon the air like oh well
of course the boy is going to sit on the Iron
Throne like all the Lords of the realm take it as
a foregone conclusion even though they just swore
fealty to rhaenyra being the heir the funny thing
about this is that George RR Martin said that
he based this event on something in real life
European history where a similar thing played
at where like a current King named his daughter
The Heir the Lords of the realm at the time and
this is happening in real life went along with it
within a little while after the king died and his
daughter was supposed to take the throne the rest
of the Lords got together and said you know what
we're going to pretend like we didn't do that
so a lot of what happens during the episode is
Princess Rhaenys being correct telling rhaenyra
in the previous episode basically nobody's gonna
go along with this no one is going to take you
seriously no no matter what you do and sure enough
even Jason Lannister who's courting her doesn't
think that she's going to be Queen we meet tyland
lannister Jason Lannister's twin informing
viserys about what's going on with the war
and the stepstones but obviously the connection
here the twins being the connection to Jamie and
Cersei being twins pretty sure they're not brother
wiving when he mentions Bloodstone that's just one
of the central areas of power inside the actual
stepstones right now in this part of the timeline
Thailand has become the current master of ships
in the small Council replacing corlys velaryon
who left obviously a couple years ago to start the
war the stepstones with Daemon it is cool to see
so much of House Lannister during this episode and
it's just a cool Twist on what the House Lannister
becomes later in the timeline when we see rhaenyra
she's back in the godswood reading that same type
of history book that she was reading earlier
reading about nymerian the 10 000 ships the song
the minstrel is playing is called the dragon's
eye it's meant to be kind of a lament like the
events of the song are basically a metaphor
for what will eventually happen in the future
head with her ships and her people her heart
broke the thing gives you a good idea what the
tensions are like between alicent and rhaenyra
like their relationship deteriorated quite a
bit over a couple years like she was betrayed
by the remarriage and now that the baby has
been born Prince aegon rhaenyra is on the outs
with her father and with alicent even though
both of them separately want to patch up their
relationships with her alicent is also very very
pregnant with her second child the second child
is a girl named Helena Targaryen because there's
going to be a year time Jump for episode three I'm
assuming we'll see that baby in episode three the
whole first half of the episode is pretty much
exclusively devoted to this hunt in the king's
wood and it gives you a lot of flashbacks for
Robert Baratheon in the Boris hunt that he went
on because there are a lot of similar moments that
kind of play off of what happened to Robert like
you have viserys drowning himself in his wine
Robert Baratheon was poisoned by Cersei or on
the command of Cersei with his wine slowly over
time and basically died because of the bore wound
rhaenyra almost dies because of a boar wound even
though someone isn't poisoning viserys like that's
not what's actually going on here his health is
just slowly deteriorating blame that on all the
sister wiving in their family speaking of which
if you notice he's wearing gloves that's because
he has a couple less digits on his hand remember
the maggots from last week's episode yep didn't
go so well they ended up having to take those
digits off you have to imagine if his health is
declining so quickly in the ensuing years what
it's going to be like in future episodes before
he passes away finally like when we see him in
next week's episode A year later he's probably
gonna be way worse part of the idea too with
him drinking all the wine I think is to numb
the pain like he just has this dull pain that
he's been living with with all the ailments all
over his body like even though he's covered we
don't see all of the ailments he's not drinking
just to get drunk or because he feels sorry
for himself he's drinking basically to numb
the actual physical pain that he's in we meet
a bunch of the other great houses during the
episode I already mentioned the Lannisters Kira
Lannister seems like their mother just based on
her age when she talks about lady Johanna being
captured she's talking about Johanna Swann who was
captured in the stepstones but her father here's
the funny thing because it's a big metaphor for
what's happening with rhaenyra Johanna Swann's
father refused to pay the ransom money so she was
basically just sold off to a pleasure house which
lady Lannister here implies is eventually going to
happen but the big twist is that Johanna after
her father refused to do anything to help her
basically became this incredibly powerful person
called The Black Swan in Lis so sort of an example
of this woman kind of cast off by her family
that nobody cares about but that made a name
for herself and became very powerful in her own
right and you can see the obvious connection to
what's happening with rhaenyra during this episode
like she feels like her father doesn't care about
her like oh you just can't wait to get rid of me
and then by the end of the episode finding this
resolve like in her station and becoming the heir
to the Iron Throne also Johanna eventually called
The Black Swan eventually rhaenyra is called
The Black Queen We Meet the rest of how strong
important characters going forward Lionel strong
the head of their household is the master of laws
right right now the sun with the walking cane
is hilarious strong he's called Laris the club
foot he was just born with a club foot obviously
as the name implies we meet his other son Harwin
strong who's very healthy and part of Daemon's
gold cloaks later in the episode as well he is
the one that kind of looks at rhaenyra like hey
hey what's going on viserys jokes about rhaenyra
marrying his son Harwin strong that'll be a big
thing in the future I don't want to get too far
ahead of this story we'll talk about that when
it actually happens because things do get pretty
spicy but like a lot of the people that they
mention here during this episode become much
bigger characters in future episodes but the other
big thing during this first half of the episode is
viserys forcing rhaenyra to get married but trying
to find the best way to do that with a little bit
of help from alicent like you have to make her
feel like she's the one making the choice which
they pay off at the end of the episode like
okay fine strengthen your claim to the Iron
Throne choose whoever you want to but you do have
to choose someone they did have that funny moment
with Jason Lannister like he was trying to spit
some game at her just completely shut him down
why would we need a dragon pit at the rock that
was meant to set up the idea that he expected
that she would not be Queen so she would be taking
her dragon to the rock where they would live they
said that the history the special ceremony of this
white staglands are supposedly going to kill and
it's going to be this big portent of right to
rule this sign of royalty what they basically
tell him is that they used to do this use this
as a symbol for a right to rule before the time
of aegon the Conqueror and in this area where
they're at here it was ruled by Harren Hoare
who is the person who built Harrenhal that's why
it's called Harrenhall maybe we'll get some of the
history of Westeros from before Aegon's Conquest
later in the series too it is cool to get those
little history lessons here and there Criston Cole
chases rhaenyra into the Kingswood sort of setting
up their relationship being a little bit closer he
claims that she's responsible for him making it on
the kingsguard like making his dream a reality
so he owes her everything you can clearly see
she has this huge crush on him probably not going
to end well for either of them also don't want to
get too far ahead of the story because obviously
he's a big character going forward when Rainier
suggests that her father can worry himself to
death the funny thing is this kind of what's
actually happening right now like he's slowly kind
of worrying himself to death even though he's not
dying of worry he's just dying of his ailments
over time slowly be careful what you wish for in
the cool moment of foreshadowing is when Criston
Cole says that the realm will accept her as Queen
because they won't have a choice obviously during
the dance of the Dragons they will have a choice
because of aegon II then they have that callback
moment to Robert Baratheon versus the boar where
rhaenyra almost gets killed by her boar but he
saves her and then she just goes to town on it
you could also look at the imagery of her being
covered in blood and then surveying everything
in the Lords of the realm from above here being
sort of a metaphor for what's going to happen
during the dance of the dragons and I think
the whole idea with the brown stag versus the
white stack is that if her father viserys had
seen the white stag and killed the white stag
that would have been a symbol to him that he
needed to name aegon the heir instead of his
daughter rhaeynra but because he doesn't see the
white tag it isn't seen as a sign of a right to
rule so he doesn't change his mind rhaenyra is
still the heir at least currently hammered home
by the idea that rhaenyra herself actually does
see the white stag like she sees this right to
rule and lets it Go free so this message just
crystallized her path forward for her she has
a much better idea of how she's going to tackle
everything going forward which is why when she
walks back into Camp she basically doesn't bother
looking at anyone who's staring at her covered in
blood really cool lore Easter egg here too when
viserys is getting drunk arguing with alicent
here about whether or not he made the right choice
in making rhaenyra the air over aegon II he says
that few in their family line have been dreamers
he's talking about Dragon dreams being born with
the ability to see visions of the future like
danis the dreamer Daenerys also had Visions in
the house and the undying those were kind of like
her Dragon dreams Dragon dreams are just a way of
describing having visions of the future there are
many characters on Game of Thrones that do that
in several different ways like bran has visions of
the future because he's one of the last greenseers
Melisandre also claims that she does the same
thing has visions of the future by staring into
the Flames getting the Visions from the Red God
when alicent's father Otto says that her son aegon
is going to be king one way or another like the
end of the road is clear despite what you want
to happen even though she wants to be friends
with bernera he's basically telling her the
realm wants aegon as the next king they'll never
accept rhaenyra just highlighting how things are
spinning out of control like they're headed on
this Collision Course and nobody really sees
a way out of it their whole conversation over
who has the stronger claim to the Iron Throne
is literally what happens during the dance of the
Dragons itself with half the realm and the greens
believing that rhaenyra is trying to steal the
Iron Throne from aegon II because it should be
his by right and the other half of the realm
thinking the aegon is usurping the throne from
rhaenyra because the king already named her
his successor alicent also sets up the idea
of rhaenyra choosing someone herself and setting
up the idea of her marrying laenor velaryon which
Lionel strong was talking to viserys about like
have her Mary laner he is a pure valerian blood
it'll strengthen the bloodline and solve a whole
bunch of problems for you because there's this
huge riff with house velaryon because he basically
threw them onto the bus when he decided to marry
alicent he needs to heal that and there's all
these problems that he has with rhaenyra trying
to figure out who she's going to get married to
so all he needs to do is have her decide to marry
laenor velaryon and make it think that it's her
choice we only get a little bit of him in this
episode so I won't talk about him too much other
than him being one of the other Dragon Riders but
there's this last moment that he has with rhaenyra
when she comes into the room and he talks about
her deciding for herself like you need to pick
a husband but you do have to pick one sooner
or later when he says he's wavered before but he
won't do it again he's talking about the bastard
that he supposedly had there's a rumor that he had
a bastard named Tristan truefire they might wind
up introducing that character later in the series
but then we actually go down to the stepstones to
dwarf Stone the place that they were talking about
like send support to dwarfstone that's the place
where they are basically in this edit the whole
idea that they are on their last legs like we're
only gonna last for a little while longer even
though we call for more ships from house velaryon
they're not going to get here for weeks I think
the whole idea is they want to show you that the
king's support was already on its way when the
letter arrived so it gets there just in time but
also Daemon's Gambit works out and they're able
to take care of crap eater and most of his forces
by the time the rest of the support gets there we
meet corlys velaryon's oldest son laenor for the
first time and his younger brother veamond this
is corlys' younger brother in the books he was
his nephew so they just kind of changed that for
the show this whole scene with veamond trying to
throw Daemon under the bus is just trying to set
up the future of their relationship together like
it's going to be very contentious it's not like
they become best friends after this or anything
like that like this sentiment between the two
of them continues the whole reason why Daemon
attacks the messenger who's doing nothing more
than just giving him the message to say that the
king is going to send them support so that they
won't die is because Daemon feels like a failure
and he feels like he can't go home so to speak
as a failure the whole idea behind this entire
campaign in his mind was yes like they got to get
rid of the triarchy and crab feeder but really he
was doing it to attain all this glory in the eyes
of the rest of the realm to prove his Worth to
the rest of the Lords basically and the whole
thing with Daemon trying to kill crap eater by
pretending to Forfeit under the white flag of
submission the way the showrunner the way that
Matt Smith talked about it is that it was sort
of like a last-ditch attempt on his part look I
want to show you how Daemon can think on his feet
he's really good in a fight but they're also kind
of playing it as if he doesn't care whether or not
he dies so a lot of the way that he fights during
this battle is meant to inform a lot of the battle
choices that he makes during the actual Dance
of the Dragons war the actual battle scene was
actually pretty cool with him attacking all the
soldiers by himself in the way they sort of played
it so that he distracted all the triarchy's forces
so that they weren't paying attention to what
the rest of House of velaryon was doing their
army basically coming up on the beachhead and what
the dragons were doing he basically pulled all the
triarchy's forces here into this tight little area
making it way easier for laner to roast them with
sea smoke in relatively speaking sea smoke is a
little bit smaller than caraxis but still pretty
large Dragon but overall not one of the bigger
dragons and that's mostly just because sea smoke
is younger than the other dragons we haven't seen
the older version of the character yet but laena
velaryon would also be a teenager at this point
you see her in the background of these trailer
shots here she's also a dragon rider as well
I don't want to talk too much about her though
before they actually introduce the older version
of the character she'll be a lot of fun in the
future like the older version of her character
is a lot of fun R.I.P to crabfeeder was hoping
we'd learn some secret about him maybe some secret
Targaryen bloodline or Valyrian bloodline in there
nope looks like they're going a different way with
that but I think the whole idea with this battle
is that Daemon proves to himself and to everyone
else that he is worthy one of the things that they
set up at the beginning of the episode though
between Daemon and his dragon karaxi is that
they kind of pay off a little bit in the end of
the episode is the whole idea that the dragon is
so closely bonded to him on this kind of psychic
level that it feels the wounds that he gets just
the same as he does so like at the beginning of
the episode when he gets hit with the arrow karaxi
is screwing teams out in pain and during the final
battle he's hit with a couple arrows you can hear
dragon cries in the background even though they
cut a lot of the audio out so you don't hear them
quite as clearly you could also make a lot of
little finger jokes during his plan of attack
here like chaos is a ladder Daemon using a lot of
the chaos and the surprise here to try and kill as
many people as possible as he gets to craft feeder
to get him but if there's any other Easter eggs
and references that you spotted during the episode
that I didn't mention during the video just write
down below in the comments and what will happen is
I'll post my episode 4 trailer video next and then
I have a couple big bonus videos planned this week
too everyone click here for that episode 4 trailer
video I'll update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for all my house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!